bonjour à tous Paris direct continue on
prend tout de suite la direction des
Pays-Bas ou Vladimir zen skill président
ukrainien s'exprime lors de sa visite de
l'assistance à l'Ukraine les pays du
Nord les Belges les Néerlandais
notre
initiative visant à mettre en place une
coalition des véhicules blindés
l'Ukraine a également besoin de chasseur
moderne il n'y a pas de raison
à retarder une décision de cette nature
il ne faut pas retarder l'entraînement
de nos pilotes l'Ukraine a besoin d'elle
l'Ukraine a besoin
d'accélérer sur ce point nous avons
échangé sur ces sujets nous avons
échangé sur nos sujets communs et nous
allons continuer à le faire
dans le cadre de notre relation
transatlantique l'Ukraine est d'ores est
déjà
un pilier de cette
alliance
de cette relation et nous la renforçons
le crâne doit devenir
un membre de
c'est pourquoi toutes les actions dans
ce sens doivent être soutenues par des
décisions politiques dans le cadre du
sommet de l'Alliance de cet été
nous comptons sur le soutien de nos
partenaires nous allons également
évoquer
les relations
Ukraine UE
nous attendons une évaluation positive
de nos progrès quant à la mise en oeuvre
des recommandations
émises par la Commission européenne nous
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons pendant
la guerre nous faisons tout ce que nous
pouvons pour accomplir pour mettre en
oeuvre ses recommandations nous espérons
obtenir un élan politique positif qui
bénéficiera à l'Ukraine et à toute
l'Europe encore un point j'aimerais
remercier
vous remercier pour votre soutien
merci
pour votre soutien qui nous permet
de garantir notre sécurité et qui nous
permettra de restaurer notre intégrité
territoriale car il s'agit infinie de la
sécurité de la salle de la stabilité de
l'Europe et du monde il s'agit de
restaurer les principes ancrés dans le
droit international et la Charte des
Nations Unies autant de choses qui ont
été violées full et au pied par Poutine
à la Russie
il faut isoler davantage la Russie pour
ces raisons il faut que les actifs de
cet état terroriste soit confisqué et
que tout ce qui a été détruit soit
réparé et que la vérité soit rétablie et
je pense je sais que nous le ferons
ensemble merci encore Marc merci encore
Alexander merci beaucoup